Welcome back. Let's do a quick summary of what you learned in Lesson 7. So we
started with a population, in this case Klout scores. The number in this
population was 1,048. The mean Klout score was 37.72. And the population
standard deviation was about 16.04. Then, we know from the central limit
theorem, that if we took all possible samples, all of the same size, and then
found the mean of each sample and then graph the distribution of those sample
means, we would get a normal curve with a mean equal to the population mean and
a standard deviation equal to the population standard deviation divided by the
square root of the sample size. Remember that this is called the sampling
distribution. In Lesson 7, we specifically looked at the sampling distribution
created from all samples of size 35. So, if we take all samples of size 35 from
this population, we find the mean of each sample, and then we plot the
distribution of sample means. The mean of the means will be the same as the
population mean, and the standard deviation of this distribution is the
population standard deviation, divided by the square root of 35, which came out
to about 2.71. Remember also, that the standard deviation of the sampling
distribution is called the standard error. Now, if we plot this sampling
distribution, it'll look something like this. One standard deviation away from
the mean would be 37.72 plus 2.71 and minus 2.71. So, we know what the
distribution should look like of all sampled means of size 35. So then we said,
what if we get this sample of size 35 and the mean is 40, and everyone in this
sample uses the app the Bieber Tweeter? The first part of this lesson is all
about estimating what the mean Klout score would be if everyone started to use
the Bieber Tweeter.